relocaliser pour limiter la casse
sociale post coronavirus c'est le
nouveau credo des manuels macron face à
la récession à venir dans sa dernière
allocution le chef de l'état a lancé un
véritable plaidoyer pour la souveraineté
économique de la france à commencer par
l'industrie pharmaceutique
mais ces paroles viande après des
décennies de désindustrialisation et
d'ouverture à la concurrence api de pays
à bas coûts alors peut-on encore revenir
en arrière aujourd'hui avec quelle
stratégie
jacques sapir envoie ça tout de suite
avec vous bonsoir jacques bonsoir
stéphanie alors jacques à vous avez dû
être plutôt satisfait en écoutant le
président est-ce que vous deviendriez
même mené au maquereau nist alors oui
c'est vrai emmanuel macron a soutenu des
idées que je défends pour ma part depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années il a
défendu en particulier l'idée de
l'indépendance nationale de la
souveraineté économique etc ce sont des
excellents de choses seulement il faut
quand même rappeler que emmanuel macron
quand il a succédé à arnaud montebourg
au ministère du redressement productif
et bien la première chose qu'il ait
faite a été de vendre alstom aux états
unis et quand il est devenu président il
a signé toute une série d'accords de
libre échange
bref on voit bien que au delà des mots
il faudrait déjà qu'il faudrait surtout
qu emmanuel macron s'il veut nous
convaincre maintenant définissent très
exactement les moyens qu'il veut engager
pour restaurer cette indépendance et
cette souveraineté économique la
question des moyens c'est très important
justement quels sons qui laissait moyens
jacques alors ses fans il faut d'abord
rappeler que ce qu'on appelle
l'indépendance stratégique ce qu'on
appelle la souveraineté économique
c'est tout d'abord faire en sorte que
des entreprises en particulier dans les
secteurs stratégiques ne partent pas à
l'étranger ou ne passent pas non plus
sous le contrôle de l'étranger alors ce
qui pose un problème c'est que dans le
cadre de la mondialisation dans le cadre
du libre échange en réalité ce ne sont
pas les produits qui sont en concurrence
c'est en réalité si vous voulez les
modèles sociaux est en fait si on veut
pouvoir lutter à armes égales avec des
pays dont les coûts sont bas mais dont
la productivité n'est pas si basses que
ça comme par exemple la chine l'inde ou
voir le vietnam eh bien il faudrait que
l'on baisse nos salaires au même niveau
on voit bien le problème alors ensuite
il ya un autre problème c'est celui des
produits de l'avenir et sur ses produits
de l'avenir il faut les identifier il
faut aussi attirer sur notre territoire
les entreprises qui pourraient avoir les
capacités de les produire
bref il faut et qu'on le veuille ou non
une forme de planification
alors donc jacques à la base il y aurait
un problème de coût du travail
oui parfaitement ces faits alors il faut
toujours rappeler une chose c'est que le
coût du travail
ces deux facteurs tout d'abord
évidemment ces deux niveaux des salaires
mais c'est aussi le niveau des
prestations sociales qui sont payés que
ce soit par les salariés ou par les
entreprises
justement pour financer un modèle social
et c'est pour ça que le libre-échange
pose un problème réel extrêmement
important sur le modèle social seulement
il ya plus
il faut rappeler une chose quand vous
avez votre souveraineté monétaire
si par exemple tu fais de progression de
votre modèle social vos coûts sont en
train de monter
évidemment votre balance commerciale se
détériore et donc naturellement votre
monnaie se déprécie ainsi c'est ce qui
s'est passé si vous voulez avec la suède
qui a laissé sa monnaie se déprécier au
début des années 2000 d'environ 20% et
qui grâce à cela a pu maintenir très
largement en l'état son modèle social
seulement nous ne pouvons plus le faire
depuis qu'il y a l'euro est là si vous
voulez il est intéressant de regarder
des calculs qui ont été réalisés par le
fonds monétaire international
enfin le fonds monétaire international a
calculé
quel était l'impact du taux de change
unique de l'euro sur des économies et on
voit très bien que en fait l'allemagne
est là
demant sous-évalué a là une économie et
une monnaie donc avec l'euro qui est
sous-évaluée alors que d'autres pays
comme la france l'italie l'espagne voire
aussi cité à la belgique ont des
monnaies qui sont fortement surévalué de
25 à 45 % et c'est ce qui explique très
largement les succès commerciaux de
l'allemagne et le fait que l'allemagne
arrive à maintenir une industrie alors
que nous comme les italiens ont comme
les espagnols nous nous des industriels
disons alors jacques le problème
concerne aussi les pays européens en
dehors de l'euro oui tout à fait parce
que si l'euro explique beaucoup de
choses
il est loin de tout expliquer et il faut
toujours rappeler une chose c'est que du
fait du libre échange et bien on a des
écarts en termes de coût du travail
et puis on a aussi les écarts en termes
de productivité sauf que ces écarts en
termes de productivité du fait de la
liberté de circulation des capitaux du
fait que cela permet des investissements
dans les pays qui ont des très bas coût
bien ne sont pas du tout du même niveau
alors prenons simplement l'exemple de la
pologne la pologne a grosso modo un coût
unitaire un coût horaire du travail qui
est à peu près de 30% voire un petit peu
en dessous du coût du travail en france
par contre si on regarde sa productivité
elle est au dessus de 55 % de la
productivité français ce qui lui donne
un avantage compétitif extrêmement
important et on peut reproduire ce
raisonnement sur la république tchèque
sur la slovaquie voire d'autres pays
comme la roumanie et la bulgarie
et donc c'est là où se posent un
problème évident alors ce problème ils
se posent au sein de l'union européenne
mais il se pose aussi avec des pays qui
sont hors union européenne
évidemment comme comme je vous le disais
la chine l'inde ou le vietnam alors
jacques est ce qu'on peut faire dans ce
cas alors ce problème est aujourd'hui
une telle ampleur que il pose en réalité
la question du libre échange et
globalement aussi du marché unique en
europe
en réalité il n'ya que le
protectionnisme qui
justement corriger ce problème et sur
cette question je rappelle que un de mes
collègues yves perez vient de publier un
livre extrêmement intéressant il ya de
cela quelques semaines voire quelques
mois
le livre est sorti au début de cette
année et qu'est ce qu'il montre et il
montre que le protectionnisme peut être
justement un instrument pour à la fois
maintenir des industries des réticences
voire aider au développement de
nouvelles industries
alors ceci dit il ya un dilemme c'est
que soit nous choisissons d'avoir des
produits qui coûte le moins cher
possible
mais à ce moment là nous acceptons une
désindustrialisation et une destruction
de l'emploi et idy destructions
d'emplois dit aussi destruction des
revenus soit nous défendons nos produits
nous défendons l'emploi
nous défendons le revenu mais ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faudra à ce moment-là
payer plus cher les produits
alors on n'y at il pas également jacques
leriche de rétorsion commerciale par ces
pays
oui tout à fait ce risque existe mais il
peut être modérée à travers deux idées
de mécanique le premier mécanisme
consiste à dire au pays voilà on va
mettre des droits de douane qui vont
compenser l'écart entre votre coût du
salaire et votre niveau de productivité
autrement dit admettons en comprennent
le cas d'un pays qui aurait un coût du
salaire à 30% du salaire français et une
productivité à 50% des remettrait 20% de
manière en fait à ramener à une égalité
entre le coût salarial et la
productivité
autrement dit à établir les bases d'une
concurrence juste vous savez c'est en
réalité cela que défend coup que devrait
défendre l'union européenne avec sa
fameuse idée de concurrence juste et non
faussée donc ça c'est une première chose
la deuxième idée que l'on peut avoir
c'est de dire un certain nombre de pays
essentiellement aux pays qui sont au
sein de l'union européenne s'ils
voulaient si on décide d'introduire des
droits de douane dans le marché lui il
consisterait à leur dire écoutez
on va vous redonner l'argent que l'on a
prélevé par ses droits de douane mais à
la condition que dans un délai
raisonnable et là il faut qu'on
s'entende évidemment sur les délits
faire sur 20 ans le faire sur peut-être
six sept ans que dans un délai
raisonnable vous fassiez converger votre
niveau de courir votre niveau de salaire
et votre niveau dont de modèle social
avec votre niveau de productivité alors
jacquin vous avez parlé jusqu'à
maintenant uniquement du taux de change
et des droits de douane mais
l'investissement ne peut-il pas aussi
intervenir dans ce processus
oui tout à fait tout à fait raisonnement
assez fainéant réalité il y a trois
piliers dans cette idée de
reconstruction d'une industrie
d'indépendance industrielle de
souveraineté économique c'est le taux de
change ce sont les droits de douane mais
il ya aussi bien entendu l'indécision et
ça c'est une chose extrêmement
importante
alors oui il va falloir que l'on
investisse massivement dans la recherche
et il faut bien dire que le cic eux si
on retrouve notre souveraineté monétaire
si on emploie des formes de
protectionnisme et bien le cic eux ne
sera plus nécessaire pour le cic très
cher à l'état et en réalité on pourrait
utiliser une partie de cet argent
il représente un peu plus de 1% du pib
soit un peu à peu près 23 milliards
d'euros par an on pourrait utiliser une
bonne partie de cet argent
justement à financer la recherche
qu'elles soient publiques ou qu'elles
soient privées
deuxième chose évidemment c'est qu'il va
falloir pour les productions innovantes
pour aider les productions innovantes
faire ce qu'on appelle des préachats
autrement dit garantir un marché aux
producteurs justement de ces produits
innovants afin de les aider à se
développer à les aider à faire des
processus de production qui deviennent
progressivement de plus en plus
compétitif sur le marché mondial
et puis
le troisième secteur dans lequel il faut
développer dans l'investissement
c'est tout ce qui concerne
l'attractivité des territoires si vous
voulez ce sont les infrastructures de
transport mais aussi les infrastructures
de santé les infrastructures de logement
bref il faut absolument développer tout
ce qui peut contribuer je dirais à la
compétitivité des territoires et pour
cela il faut sonder en avoir conscience
il faudra une forme aussi de
planification par exemple ça pourrait
être l'occasion de recréer la délégation
générale aux plans qui existait dans les
années 40 et jusqu'à la fin des années
90 mais peut-on faire tout ce qu'une
base un jacques purement française non
non c'est très clair à stéphanie et il
va falloir de ce point de vue là que
l'état prenne l'initiative de provoquer
des coopérations ou d'inciter à des
coopérations de soutenir des entreprises
qui voudraient s'engager dans des
coopérations internationales et je vais
vous donner un exemple dans le domaine
de la pharmacie
emmanuel macron annoncé et c'est une
excellente chose que la france avait
décidé avec quatre autres pays de fait
un fonds commun pour pouvoir acheter des
vaccins une fois qu'ils seront produits
mais il faut bien comprendre ce n'est
pas du tout une initiative de lieux ce
dont il est question là c'est de la
simple coopération inter gouvernementale
donc c'est cela qu'il faut faire c'est
d'ailleurs cela qui avait fonctionné
avec airbus airbus n'est pas un
programme lié à l'union européenne de
même que a rien à rien n'est pas un
programme non plus lié à l'union
européenne se sont au départ des
coopérations internationales alors le
problème aussi c'est que il ne faudrait
pas se limiter dans cette coopération
internationale
au pays de l'union européenne il
faudrait faire des coopérations
internationales avec d'autres pays la
suisse en particulier qui est un pays
extrêmement dynamique dans les produits
innovants
on peut penser à singapour on peut
penser à l'inde
et on peut penser bien entendu à la
russie 1 conclusion jacques les mesures
que vous proposez ou qui me semble
souhaitable une petite différence les
avez-vous retrouvé non allocution
emmanuel macron t stéphanie vous dire
une chose
macron n'est pas arnaud montebourg
si vous êtes son projet tel qu'il
l'avait présenté en 2010 s était grosso
modo de faire pour la france une
économie qui aurait associé à un
mouvement des start up dans l'économie
numérique
avec le développement de la finance à
travers la crise du coc vie de 19
je pense qu'il a compris que ce modèle
ne correspondait pas à un pays de 67
millions d'habitants si on était trois
ou quatre millions d'habitants
ça aurait peut-être fonctionner mais sur
une population de 67 millions
d'habitants ça ne peut pas fonctionner
et il a donc compris qu'il devait avoir
un vrai modèle de réindustrialisation et
de développement de l'indépendance
économique
le problème c'est que tant qu'on ne
prendra pas le taureau par les cornes et
tant qu'il ne prendra pas le taureau par
les cornes sur les questions de coût du
travail tant qu'il ne posera pas la
question de la souveraineté monétaire
quand tu ne posera pas la question d'un
protectionnisme voire d'un
protectionnisme altruistes comme je lé
défendu eh bien ça ne pourra pas
fonctionner prenons le cas par exemple
des subventions qui sont donnés
aujourd'hui si vous voulez vous équiper
avec des panneaux solaires
c'est une très bonne idée ça fait
progresser évidemment ce qu'on appelle
l'économie vert sauf que ces panneaux
solaires on en produit pratiquement plus
en france on en produit pratiquement
plus en allemagne
et si on veut en acheter il faut aller
les acheter en chine
on voit bien là tout le problème qui se
pose et ça a été une erreur dramatique
de l'ex est justement la concurrence
détruire l'industrie des panneaux
solaires en france et en allemagne
donc si vous voulez le discours
des manuels macron ne pourra avoir un
minimum de crédibilité je dirais même
plus il ne pourra être audible que quand
il abordera effectivement cette question
du taux de change
et cette question du protectionnisme
merci jacques pour toute cette analyse
qui nous a donné à réfléchir merci à
vous et à bientôt sur rt france